well this street is the site of an
active investigation police say a woman
hit and killed a pedestrian then took
off it happened January 21st near Lake
Mead and Hollywood according to reports
the car involved stops at a convenience
store down the street where the driver
changes clothes and wipes down the car
before speeding through the site of the
crash a second time police arresting
19-year-old Joanna Mesa speaking with
detectives Mesa admits to drinking with
friends before leaving and colliding
with quote something on the way Denise
well Brian that something was 24 year
old rikaya Poole she died in the crash
and tonight her family Express is
speaking exclusively to eight news now
about that deadly hit and run Madison
Kimbrough is live from the Clark County
Detention Center with more Madison
yeah that deadly crash was more than a
week ago with the suspect eventually
tracked down and charged a few days ago
she's now being held at the Clark County
Detention Center now earlier tonight I
spoke with family members of the victim
rakaya Poole who want to know why she
was walking in the street and why the
driver who hit her never stopped
she was strong she was a strong young
woman
and she had dreams and aspirations and
she wanted the best for her son Angel
Chadwick and her mother Glenda
remembering her niece 24 year old rakaya
Poole Poole was riding in the car with
friends when for some reason they came
to a stop and she got out
and while walking was killed outside a
marked crosswalk in this intersection
her family is still coming to terms with
it it's really hard
to even accept that you know her life
was cut off at such a
early age according to the arrest report
19-year-old Joanna Mesa was speeding on
East Las Vegas Boulevard when she
allegedly hit and killed pool Meza
didn't stop and kept driving while she
hasn't been charged with a DUI Poole's
family believes she may have been
intoxicated hey young lady they hit my
niece
there were other people in the car with
her
and
I feel like everybody should be held
accountable she was 19 years old where
did she get the alcohol from
so whoever house she was at whoever
supplied her with the alcohol
they need to be a held accountable as
well her grandmother is urging the other
people who were in the car with rakaya
to help them understand what happened I
pray and hope that they could you know
give some answers to why did she get out
the car
because that hasn't been explained yet
why did she get out all we know that
they were Oregon
and she was actually
and that was it
Joanna Mesa is facing charges of
reckless driving failing to stop at the
scene of an accident and destroying and
concealing evidence now she's scheduled
to appear in court that's going to be on
February 6. reporting live from the
Clark County Detention Center Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now